hi hi it's nice to meet you and you you
are so fantastic in this film I'm so
excited about it how do you keep filming
light on set because it is you know a
heavy is that heavy film yeah I think it
really helps when you're working with
really lovely people and Alexander
Skarsgard and Jason Clark are just the
loveliest and James Kent the director I
mean this is it's weird because this is
a very emotional intense film it's one
of the nicest films if not the nicest
job I've ever done and I think that's
just because everybody was just like
lovely and I think it's funny when
you're sort of dealing with something
like this you almost need to kind of you
know the camera turns on and and you get
it out and that's when you do it and
then when it's off it's not like it's
jokey it was just very supportive and
very it was just it was just like a
lovely group of people yeah so that
helps yeah powders being a mom effect
the films that you take on um oh god I
mean it does affect the films I take on
I think it obviously completely changes
your life in every way so it probably
changes the way that I see the world and
therefore the stuff that I'm interested
in but also just on a practical level
it's like I you know I can no longer
kind of go yeah let's go into the middle
of nowhere for six months where you're
going to need 10 million injections and
there is absolutely nothing to do for a
three-year-old you know so the literally
where things are is is making me take
them or turn them down now which it
never used to you know that was never a
kind of consideration and it very
definitely is now so that's changed a
lot will we ever see you on social media
I don't think I'd be very good at it
there's so glam not really I mean you're
glad on these days yeah sure I've got
like a whole team of people doing it but
like normally I'm not um I mean I can't
imagine it but you never know yeah
hey you want yeah you're on it I'm on it
you're on everyone at BYU oh thank you I
don't think I'd be very interesting on
it either no
you think so no so you've opened up
you've been pretty open about just your
image in your early 20s and struggling
with that hmm but in this film we see
you have some pretty steamy scenes of
support a double that really was I mean
it really was a body that well I mean
she looks amazing
what are you my buddy no no I do you
believe me it wasn't my body I mean my
body's fine but it's not like that
what yeah no it was somebody else's body
no no it's the magic of movies that's
what you can do now yeah I promise I
don't have boobs like that or a bum like
that it was shoes look great but it
wasn't me so no steamy scenes well I did
the this bit yeah but not any of no not
anything below this bit I'm gonna have
to watch you're gonna have to watch
again it's blown your mind my god how is
that possible yeah no but [ __ ] so the
naked bit is not me okay I'm so I did it
like that
fun fact much fun fact not my buddy
right buddy but not mine was there a
favorite part about working on this film
I think it won I honestly it was the
people it's just it was it was so nice
to work with such lovely supportive
talented you know I mean I've worked
with Jason Clark before and I just love
working with him he's just he's so fun
to work with you never know kind of what
he's gonna do and it's ya really have to
kind of step into the ring with him but
he's so unbelievably supportive and
lovely and Alexander is one of the
nicest men in the entire world so I
think just having that kind of you know
it felt like a real team might really
lovely lovely vibe so I think that you
know it will forever in my mind be one
of the nicest films that I've ever
worked on it was a pleasure talking to
you my dear I do thank you very fun I'm
gonna watch I see ya the boob and me are
never in the same shot
you